What are you doing later? Wanna come over to my place tomorrow, play mario kart?
I have to go meet my future stepbrother.
He just got out of rehab. Try to be nice.
Is that him? He's hot!
Oh I know, that's Shadi. That's the sponsor.
So that's not Luke?
Now there's Luke.
Damn! Junkies are supposed to be skinny!
So... Erica you must be psyched to have a older brother type in the house.
Totally psyched. You get to have a complete stranger living in my home.
No offence, buddy.
Babe! Are you okay?
I really want to punch you in the face right now. I just don't want to ruin those
Lip injections that daddy gave you.
At least my daddy is not in jail.
Luke's a complicated little guy, he's accused a teacher of (clears throat)
Fondling him. Thinks he saw him around town.
Shaking down a child molester is our moral obligation.
Nobody's going anywhere until we see this guy molest somebody.
I don't think he will he's like a pro, that's what you get like a subterranean dungeon for.
What?!
Totally!
Do I know you?
I'm sorry?
Bowling alley! You're hot old guy, me my friends, we've been oggling your goodies for like the last six months
My goodies?
Yeah.
Oh my god. Okay
So what's the plan?
What if we break in and tie him up?
Yeah, dom him like he's our a little bitch
Surprise!
I'm not stalking you or anything. As you can tell I have like major daddy issues.
Where were you last night?
With my friends.
Doing what?
A little bit up.
Did you get it?
No, I'm trying to find the right filter.
Buying tampons like what's it to you?
Hi!
(scream)
What just happened?
We're vigilantes!
Cheers!
Are you okay?
No, I'm obviously not okay
Where are you guys going?
To go buy some crack, you know, throw it down.
(whispering) It's okay. They're not buying drugs Bob. Just let them hang out.
Oh, I get the joke.
You